Earlier, we found that
when there are two terms,
addition follows
the commutative property.
But, what about when
there are three terms?
What if Katy bought two cameras
from an electronics store and
then ordered five cameras from
an electronics website, and
then ordered three more cameras
from a different website?
We can use parentheses to
group Katy's online purchases.
So, Katy bought two cameras in person
and then 5 + 3 cameras online.
Is that different than if Katy purchases
two cameras at an electronics store
five at an electronics wholesaler and
three online?
Here, I'm going to use
parentheses to group
the cameras that Katie
purchased in person.
True or false, 2 + 5 + 3 is
the same thing as 2 + 5 + 3?